[Music]
How are you greetings from Cristian Cásseres with
his brief News Now report in
Spanish? The authorities are
investigating an accident in which the
driver fled the scene. This happened
around eight thirty on
Thursday night at a ranch in Washington.
police say a person was
crossing the assigned crosswalk with their
corresponding lights on when they were
hit by a dark colored vehicle
the driver never stopped
anyone with information please
contact 70 23 85 55 55 and
released a promising
related report  to the economy during the month
of march the government says
employers added more than 900,000
new jobs last month this
would mark the best month in
a pandemic year there is also good
news for nevada as the improvement was
seen in  jobs related to the
hotel industry unemployment in the usa
dropped 6%
and the welcome to las vegas sign
Paint blue this Friday as a
show of support for World
Autism Day County leaders gathered
at the sign to turn on the
respective lights on this very special day and
now we turn to the weather forecast,
I tell you that we will have
warm temperatures for today but it is expected  a
hot sunny weekend in the valley
reaching listen to this 90
degrees temps will be back in the
80s next week i'm cristian
cásseres and this is your
news now preview in spanish